so
you know what it takes to build a
successful startup but you're also an
investor
in a lot of successful startups let me
ask for
advice what do you think it takes to
build a successful startup
by way of advice well i think it starts
i mean everything starts and even ends
with the founder
and so i think it's really really
important to look at the founders
motivations and their sophistication
about what they're doing
in almost all cases that i'm familiar
with and have thought hard about
you've had a founder who was deeply
deeply inculcated
in the domain of technology that they
were taking on
now what's interesting about that is you
could say you know wait how is that
possible because there's so many young
founders when you look at young founders
they're generally coming out of very
nascent emerging fields of technology
we're simply being present and accounted
for and engaged in the community for a
period of even
months is enough time to make them very
very deeply inculcated i mean you look
at mark andreessen
and netscape you know mark had been
doing visual
web browsers when netscape had been
founded for what a year and a half but
he created the first one
you know and in mosaic when he was an
undergrad
and the commercial internet was
pre-nascent in 1994 when that escape was
was founded
so there's somebody who's very very deep
in their domain mark zuckerberg also
social networking very deep in his
domain even though it was not nascent at
the time
lots of people doing crypto stuff i mean
you know in the you know
ten years ago even seven or eight years
ago by being a really really
vehement and engaged participant in the
crypto
ecosystem you could be an expert in that
you look
however more established industries take
salesforce.com
salesforce automation pretty mature
field when it got started who's the
executive and the founder
um mark benioff who spent 13 years at
oracle
and was an investor in siebel systems
which ended up being salesforce's main
competition
so you know more established you need
the entrepreneur
to be very very deep in the technology
and the culture
and the winter of the space because you
need that entrepreneur that founder
to have just an unbelievably accurate
intuitive sense
for where the puck is going right and
that only comes
from being very deep so that is sort of
factor number one and the next thing is
that that founder needs to be
charismatic
and or credible or ideally both
in exactly the right ways to be able to
attract
a team that is bought into that vision
and is bought into that founder's
intuitions being correct
and not just the team obviously but also
the investors
so it takes a certain personality type
to pull that off
then the next thing i'm still talking
about a founder is
a relentlessness and indeed a mono mania
to put this above things that
might rationally you know should perhaps
rationally supersede it for a period of
time
um to just relentlessly pivot when
pivoting is called for and it's always
called for i mean
think of even very successful companies
like how many times did
facebook pivot you know news feed was
something that was completely alien to
the original version
of facebook and came found
foundationally important how many times
in google how many
times had any given how many times is
apple pivoted you know that
founder energy in dna when the founder
moves on the dna that's been inculcated
with a company
has to have that relentlessness and that
ability to pivot and pivot and pivot
without
you know being worried about sacred cows
and then the last thing i'll say about
the founder before i get to the rest of
the team and
that'll be mercifully brief is the
founder
has to be obviously a really great hirer
but just important a very good fire
and firing is a horrific experience for
both people
involved in it it is a wrenching
emotional experience
and being good at realizing when
this particular person is damaging the
interests of the company
and the team and the shareholders and
you know
having the intestinal fortitude to have
that conversation and make it happen
is something that most people don't have
in them
and it's something that needs to be
developed in most people
um or maybe some people have it
naturally but without
that ability that will take an a plus
organization into b minus range very
very quickly
and um so that's all what needs to be
present and the
founder can just say sure how damn good
you are rob that was brilliant
the the one thing that was kind of
really kind of surprising to me
is um having a deep technical knowledge
because um i think the way you expressed
it which is
that allows you to be really honest with
the capabilities of
what like what's possible
like of course you're often trying to do
the impossible
but in order to do the impossible you
have to be quote unquote impossible but
you have to be honest with what is
actually possible it doesn't
necessarily have to be the technical
competence it's got to be in my view
just a complete immersion in that
emerging market and so i
can imagine there are a couple people
out there who have started really good
crypto
projects who themselves aren't right in
the code
but they're immersed in the culture and
through the culture and a
deep understanding of what's happening
and what's not happening they can get a
good intuition
of what's possible but the very first
power higher
um i mean oh good great way to solve
that is to have a technical co-founder
and you know dual founder companies have
become extremely
common for that reason uh and if you're
not doing that
and you're not the technical person but
you are the founder
you've got to be really great at hiring
a
very damn good technical person very
very fast
can i can i on the founder ask you is it
possible
to do this alone there's so many people
giving advice
and saying that it's impossible to do
the first few steps not impossible but
much more difficult to do it alone
if we were to take the journey saying
this especially in the software world
where there's not
significant investment required for to
build something up yeah
is it possible to go to the uh
to a prototype to something that
essentially works and already has a huge
number of customers
alone sure um there are lots and lots of
low f
loan founder companies out there that
have made an incredible difference
i mean i'm not certainly putting
rhapsody in the league of spotify we
were too early to be spotify but we did
an awful lot of innovation
and then after the company sold and
ended up in the hands of real networks
and mtv
you know got to millions of subs right i
was alone founder
and i studied arabic and middle eastern
history undergrad
so i def wasn't very very technical but
yeah loan founders can absolutely work
and the advantage of a loan founder
is you don't have the catastrophic
potential
of a falling out between founders i mean
two founders
who fall out with each other badly can
rip a company to shreds
because they both have an enormous
amount of equity an enormous amount of
power and the capital structure is a
result of that
they both have an enormous amount of
moral authority
with the team as a result of each having
that founder role
and i have witnessed over the years
many many situations in which companies
have been shredded
or have suffered near fatal blows
because of a falling out between
founders and the more founders you add
the more risky that becomes i i i don't
think there should ever
almost i mean you never say never but
multiple founders beyond two
um is such an unstable and potentially
treacherous situation
that i would never ever recommend going
beyond two but i do see value
in the non-technical sort of business
and market and outside-minded
founder teaming up with the technical
founder um
there is a lot of merit to that but
there's a lot of danger in that unless
those two blow apart
was it lonely for you unbelievably and
that's the drawback
i mean if you're a lone founder
there is no other person that you can
sit down with
and tackle problems and talk them
through who has precisely
or nearly precisely your alignment of
interests
your most trusted board member uh is
likely an investor
and therefore at the end of the day has
the interest of preferred stock in mind
not
common stock your most trusted vp
um who might own a very significant
stake in the company
doesn't own anywhere near your stake in
the company and so their long-term
interest
may well be in getting the right uh
level of experience and credibility
necessary to peel off and start their
own company
or their interests might be aligned with
you know
jumping ship and and and setting up with
another with
with a different company whether it's a
rival or one in a completely different
space
so yeah being a lone founder is a
spectacularly lonely thing and
that's a major downside too what about
mentorship because you're a mentor to a
lot of people
can you find an alleviation to that
loneliness and the space of ideas
with a good mentor with a good mentor
like a mentor who's mentoring you
yeah yeah you can a great deal
particularly if it's somebody who's been
through this very process and has
navigated it successfully
and cares enough about you and your
well-being being
to give you you know beautifully
unvarnished advice that can be a huge
huge
thing that can assuage things a great
deal and i had a board member
who who was not an investor who
basically played that role for me to a
great degree he came in
maybe halfway through the company's
history though i would have needed that
the most in the very earliest days
yeah the loneliness um
it's the whole journey of life we're
always alone alone together
it pays to embrace that you were
saying that there might be something
outside of the founder that's also
that you were promising to be brief on
yeah okay so
we talked about the founder you were
asking what makes a great startup yes
and great founder is thing number one
but then thing number two and it's
ginormous is a great team
and so i said so much about the founder
because
one hopes or one believes that a founder
who is a great hirer
is going to be hiring people and in
charge of critical functions like
engineering and marketing and biz dev
and sales and so forth
who themselves are great hirers but what
needs to radiate from the founder into
the team that might be a little bit
different from what's
in the gene code of the founder the team
needs to be fully bought in to
the you know the intuitions and the
vision of the founder
great we've got that but um
the team needs to have a slightly
different thing which is
you know its 99 obsession
is execution is to relentlessly hit the
milestones hit the objectives
hit the quarterly goals that is you know
one percent vision
you don't want to get lose that but
execution
machines you know people who have a
demonstrated ability
and a demonstrated focus on yeah i go
from point to point
to point i try to beat and raise
expectations relentlessly
never fall short and you know both sort
of blaze and follow the path
not that the path is getting straight i
mean blaze the trail as well i mean
a good founder is going to trust that vp
of sales
to have a better sense of what it takes
to build out that organization what the
milestones be and it's going to be kind
of a dialogue amongst those
at the top but you know execution
obsession
in the team is the next thing yeah
there's some sense where the founder
you know you talk about sort of the
space of ideas like first principles
thinking
asking big difficult questions of like
future trajectories or having a big
vision
and big picture dreams you can almost be
a dreamer
it feels like when you're like not the
founder but
in the space of sort of leadership
but when it gets to the ground floor
there has to be execution there has to
be
hitting deadlines and uh
sometimes those are attention there's
something about
dreams that um
our attention with the pragmatic nature
of execution
not dreams but sort of ambitious vision
and uh though those have to be i suppose
coupled
the vision in the leader and the
execution
in the in the software world that would
be the programmer
or the designer absolutely
you